so i think the story of how i got into
engineering and computer science is kind
of a story of uh
lucky or unlucky coincidences depending
on how we look at it
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders thanks for having me
so great to have you you know software
engineering director at google
co-founder of the amazing program mind
the gap but i don't want to talk about
google
i don't want to talk about what's
happening today i want to go back i want
to hear your story
because it's such an it's an incredible
incredible inspiration for me when i
first heard it a few months ago when we
had coffee
back when you were allowed to have
coffee with another person in the same
room and not over zoom
mikhail take me away to your childhood
how how do you enter the engineering
world
so i think the story of how i got into
engineering and computer science is kind
of a story of uh
lucky or unlucky coincidences depending
on how we look at it
and it's all it's all been kind of
happening by chance
so growing up i was always
exposed to computers and said that i i
had two older brothers and they were
very much into computer science
but my exposure was uh i would say
almost negative i was
very adamant and very convinced on one
thing that there is absolutely no way
that i would go into computer science
i looked at it as this geeky and
programming in general right i looked at
it
as this geeky thing that my older
brothers are doing and there was no way
that someone
as cool as me
it was something that i was very it was
very much a part of
how i thought of in fact there was even
stories that run in my family about the
time where
everyone tried to teach me how to
program uh
and there was really a family effort
where my brothers and my parents all
kind of gave it their own shot and wow
at different times we'll reach pretty
much the same conclusions like computer
science and programming it's just
not for me and is that just because
you're not
enjoying it you're not willing to try it
out why why why did you reach that
conclusion
or why did everybody else reach that
conclusion um so
i actually interviewed them uh not too
long ago and kind of asked them about it
um and one think that they of course uh
um
attractively they all give slightly
different things than i think what i
what they thought at the time uh but it
was a mix of uh
what they perceived as lack of interest
and uh
at best there and maybe lack of skill if
you look at some of uh
how they uh how they perceive our
interactions around computer science and
programming and right
um so i i think that from from my
perspective and i think i kind of
suppressed that whole experience because
i didn't remember it as well as
they all did but i think that kind of
reflecting back
i just didn't think of it as something
that would make sense for me to do and i
didn't really understand what
programming is and what programming
potentially enable
um in in my life and in general uh so i
kind of
took it for what it was which was okay
you type things in the computer and then
it like
spits out numbers at you or does
something at you uh and i didn't quite
make that connection
uh and i think the other the other
component is that i
didn't even perceive myself as the type
of person
uh that could potentially do this right
my the only people who i knew that were
programming at the time were basically
my two older
brothers or my two geeky older brothers
right
honestly it wasn't something that i felt
very connected to
and i what ultimately did uh clearly
change things for me because obviously
how things have changed was actually
uh the military so i was born and raised
in israel and of course when you're 18
there's a mandatory military service
and one thing that the military isn't
does very well is
utilize all its possible resources um
and basically they ran me through a
series of tests at the end of which
um they decided that um computer
programming is something that i could
potentially be quite
quite good at so differently from your
brothers and your parents they don't ask
you and come up with a conclusion you're
not fit they tell you
mikhail for the next three years you're
gonna be as a computer programmer
exactly i even remember that they asked
me there was like a an interview
an in-person interview they asked me
would you be interested in that and i
said no
for me the military takes your input
into consideration but ultimately that's
what's best for the military
right um and that's kind of how i
i guess discovered this so you so you
become a computer
you can become a software engineer you
know fast forward a few years and you're
already
you know you're a very very successful
software engineer and within google a
director
within google but you know looking back
in in retrospective so obviously you
love what you're doing i mean you're a
geek
we can say now i am proud but
going back to your childhood that was
something that you weren't really
willing to accept and and i think that
you know i actually can relate very very
well to what you're saying
the first lines of code that i really
wrote were in the military
and even though i come from a very techy
and geeky household i was never
really into computer programming now i
love
programming both at stanford and at
hippo where i work and also in the idf
why do you think that you weren't
interested in computer sensor why
weren't you open to
to exploring it back when you were a kid
i think this thing that um my story
you know when i reflect back what i
think of it is that success and
being successful something is very
situational right
and as a leader it's important for me to
remember
it's not that someone is not good at
something right
oftentimes it's that someone hasn't been
exposed to something in the right way
that just makes things
clean or sometimes it's that some
the people don't perceive themselves as
being able to excel at something
and i think that in my case it was
probably a combination where
um i both didn't perceive myself as
someone who could
do uh this type this line of work but
also i think it just
it might not have been the right time or
the right way to introduce me into
computer science and
i was actually quite shocked because you
know when i talked to my brother who
probably uh um was the one who was able
to uh
persevere longest and his attempts to
try and
teach me very basic computer science
science concepts uh
the things that he said that i couldn't
grasp at the time are things that are
quite trivial right so i think it was
more of a matter of
me being open to it and also how it was
taught
and somehow when i was you know 18 in
the military something just clicked
uh and from there on it just kind of
flowed i mean i mean it resonates a lot
with with a very interesting
conversation i had with another leader
the other day
where they were talking about how you
know when you're when you're managing
somebody and they're not living up to
their potential
by keeping them on the team and by not
giving them concrete feedback or
sometimes you know firing them when you
need to
you're actually doing a disservice to
them because you're not allowing them to
live up to the potential and maybe it's
situational that in the current in the
current place where they're at
they're not able to do that maybe they
do have the skills but they're just not
able to explore them
and to bring them to fruition but you
know you're taking your own experience
and then you did something really
amazing with it and you
knew it helped create created an
organization called mind the gap so tell
me a little bit about what that is
and and how that helped inspire other
other girls to go into tech
so mind the gap is a program that i
started with uh daniela reichmann who is
also
an engineering manager and is a close
friend of mine we started it
i think it was in 2009 so quite some
time ago with a
with the goal of exposing um some girls
to computer science and programming
and i think we took a pretty um
i would say uh self-centered point of
view and things and we both had quite
similar stories of how we got into
programming and uh
being resistant to it at that critical
age um
and we basically wanted to create
something that would cater to our
younger selves and try to
expose our younger selves to computer
science programming and
show us what we see in it today right um
now what what is the younger self so
what age are we talking about which is
really
the critical age that you've that you've
understood is where you should inject
yourself in
so it's around junior high school um the
reason we chose that age is because
if you look at the funnel of when uh
girls and minorities kind of drop
out of uh i would say the path towards
computer science that's around the time
that it happened
in israel it's in particular pronounced
because all the uh
ap classes uh the selection of
what you do your aps and basically
happens at that time right because so in
israel differently than in a lot of
other places especially the
us you actually choose a profession back
already in high school where you choose
what is your specialization
and uh and and where so and and so and
israel is very well known for that right
that
very early on you have to sort of choose
what is your path and
oftentimes after the army and after you
usually go to india or
or south america you rediscover your
your roots and what you want to do
so okay so interesting so you go in and
what do you actually do with these young
women
and and what impact does this have
so we basically try to think of what are
the main causes that
uh phrases strong and right and i think
much like the story that i thought about
myself it's a
mix of things so one is um they many of
them just don't understand what computer
science is
it seems as this like cold thing where
you do something at the computer all by
yourself and something happens and
it doesn't really relate your day-to-day
lives um
it's perceived as a profession that is
very solitary
where you don't actually work with more
people and you don't have to
leverage any people skills that you
might have and
and finally there aren't enough
unfortunately role models
so even so even if you don't
uh necessarily even if you know what
computer science is you don't
necessarily think of yourself as someone
who could go in that path just because
you don't
see yourself in the people who are
successful so it's almost like a chicken
and the egg problem because
you could yeah it's self-explanatory
yeah so we basically started um office
visits
at the google office where um initially
there were a monthly basis later on a
weekly basis where we would bring
in a group of girls and we would give
them a
a lecture a technical talk about
computer science
and the way that we tailored it is very
much explaining how computer science
touches our day-to-day lives right
computer sciences everywhere it's in our
phones uh it's in our cars it's all
around us so creating that connection
and making them
see the impact that they could have on
people's lives via computer science
was one very important thing then we
also had a panel where
we brought in um different types of uh
disciplines under computer science the
computer science or engineering umbrella
right there is uh product management
software engineering
uh um there is uh ux
user experience research and many many
other things just to show the diversity
of skills that one might need or might
be able to leverage
uh when going down that uh that path
i have to say that i relate so much to
what you're saying because just like
this i i was under the same impression
you know going through high school and i
took ap computer science i knew
java i knew it whatever but but i still
thought that yes it's just about you
know writing code there's no
relationship to
what to to the real life and honestly
it's also because the curriculum
in school is very it's very it's in a
cube you don't really understand
the connection to computers outside you
learn the algorithms and you learn the
math but you don't learn how it impacts
you
now i mean in 2020 literally almost
everything in the room here
has an operating system everything has a
brain and
i consider myself a product guy i
consider myself as someone who loves
people i love user experience
but because i i have this knowledge of
computer science i'm able to actually
think about what products i could
potentially build
and i'm so thankful that i got that the
army pushed me to learning this
and that's why i can relate so well to
what you're saying because as a high
schooler
and in middle school there's it's so
hard to understand this
it's basically the way i think
programming is a tool that gives you
this magical ability
to build the things that could uh change
people's lives right
and this is what my gap is about showing
that to younger girls
um and the program has been going on for
uh 10 years just over 10 years now
wow there's about 5 000 girls a year
that go through it
5 000 girls a year yeah oh my god
wow that's incredible
yeah so it's basically i hope the next
generations
of computers women computer scientists
will go through it
and it keeps evolving and keep changing
based on feedback that we get and you
know things that we see are working and
they're not working and i i should say
that
uh daniella and i are no longer actively
running the program it's been
there's basically a new generation of
amazing leaders that are
doing this wonderful wonderful work and
i think that's a part of what i i
quite like about it the fact that it's
not built around daniella or around me
it's built around the actual content
and i think that's a huge vote of
confidence that you have this
inspiration for others to continue with
it
and 5 000 girls a year that's just
incredible so you know
most people when they think of board of
directors they think of you know people
who come in and they have you know power
over your
over your your organization or over your
work they have
you're voting a lot you have to please
them what it sounds to me is that you ha
you're you form these group of mentors
that you
deeply respect and they respect you and
it's they're not voting on anything and
you're not trying to please them but
but the there are people who are
following your journey and when you say
that they're invested
in in this it mean it means that they've
invested in their relationship right
they they believe you and
and they love working with you or they
love helping you achieve your potential
yeah it's basically um it's basically
that and often times with people who
i've
worked with in the past no problem
good so yeah it is very much that it's
people who
uh oftentimes have either worked with or
have met professionally
otherwise and there's always something
that i deeply respect and want to learn
from them
right and we try to i would hope that
it's also mutual and there's something
that
you know some of them would want to
learn to learn from me but
it's um it's definitely focused about
the thing that i admire about this
person the thing i want to
get their opinion on i love it i want to
go i want to go up 30 000 feet in the
air and i want to look
you know as an overview of what's
happening today in the space we can go
on you know on on things like mine the
gap where we can go talk about different
experiences you have
but what are some of the biggest
challenges you think that we're facing
now in the industry
with computer science whether that's on
the education perspective or the
personal fulfillment perspective
because now you're a leader you're
managing a quite a few people within
within a large organization like google
you've you've gone through this whole
experience yourself
with mentors and i'd love to pick your
brain over the next few minutes
what are the biggest challenges and what
can i take with me as a young engineer
as a young entrepreneur
and keeping in mind for the future so
first i think that opid is one of the
things that
pretty much reshaped and got a lot of
leaders
myself included to rethink things that i
decided for grant
the ability to uh talk to you to your
peers face to face or to meet people
and how to create this um um
it's effectively a new leadership style
where right
you find yourself talking to a computer
or to a camera and
you might not even see all the people
that you're talking to so it's
it's very different than what we're used
to and how to adjust running an
organization where
people have lives people have kids and
where do you create that boundary right
where we work and live in the same place
right now right so when is work when is
life
how do you mix the teeth so i think that
is definitely something that
i don't have a good answer on just yet
but it's definitely something that i am
thinking of and how should i adapt my
that my leadership style
i mean it sounds like something that
every almost every manager in the world
now has to adapt to because
not nobody really experienced this
before this magnitude of lack of
work-life balance when
the sofa is both work and your sofa
and different people of course are
impacted differently right if you think
of parents they're probably a population
that
has a much more difficult time and their
their challenges are quite different
than maybe
someone who lives on their own and maybe
even uh social distancing
is more difficult than that person so i
think each person has very different
needs
uh and it's important for leaders and
organizations to
think of that take that into
consideration and not necessarily expect
it's not a mold that you can apply for
every person can apply
totally michal what are you most excited
about in computer science
in the industry the field that i work on
which is natural language understanding
interview is something that i'm
personally very excited about i think
that it's
uh it's an area that's uh that's been
evolving very rapidly
things like bird and basically you see
these abilities that
maybe years ago seemed like science
fiction or something that's
you know think of the turing test as an
example right
[Music]
you're supposed to uh i think you're
supposed to recognize whether or not
a person is speaking to it or on a
computer right
and i think that the advancements that
were made are quite impressive
on state-of-the-art investments and i
think that now we're starting to see
those uh basically being built at scale
by a lot of the
larger companies by google being one of
them
so sure that's an airport that i think
will keep evolving and i think that we
will see
more more applications and products of
the technology that
we know is there and i think that the
challenge there is twofold so one is
finding
the right set of products and how to
leverage that in a way that's
uh um engaging on the one hand and
uh doesn't have the creepy element let's
say uh
on the other hand right um and on the
other hand i think
a very technical challenge of how to
apply these algorithms at scale
uh when you think of the scale that uh
on products like
google and some of the other ones needed
so for me i think that applies
um for a very wide set of challenges
i think it's fascinating that you get to
build products and work on technologies
at the end they
impact immediately you know hundreds of
millions of customers
uh you know it's something that i think
any engineer
can only dream of of getting to really
having a production code run and impact
the lives
of so many people and i think that's
probably the most incredible motivation
you can have
for building great products because i
know that you know a lot of people are
are passionate on for algorithms for the
sake of algorithms
you know i know about myself i'm
passionate about impact and and how to
use the
technologies and deep technologies to
impact the lives of people
i think what you're doing there is just
incredible and mikhail before we leave i
have to put you on the spot one last
time and i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
three words wow um engineer the hardest
question but you already know the answer
okay engineer
persistent mother
engineer persistent mother it's it
sounds like
that order i love it
thank you very much and best of luck to
these difficult times
thank you it was great thanks for having
me take care bye
you